listen congrats on the movie
thank you uh i think i'm always
fascinated to learn like behind the
scenes of the making of a film so
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of f-nut
so with f9 um we didn't get to travel to
tokyo
they had to build tokyo in the set in in
england
in london and i remember
i was training so hard for the action
sequence with anna
and with michelle and um we kept waiting
for that to be built but as you saw it
was like a very intricate
really stunning um really stunning set
and it took so long to build that we
never got to actually train
at that set so we built this little set
with cardboard boxes and they were like
here's the stove where you're gonna like
sit on and then kick the bad guy
and then this is these are the makeshift
drawers made out of cardboard so we just
trained with cardboards
a little cardboard kitchen for for weeks
and weeks before the set was actually
built
that's one thing that would probably
surprise a lot of people
um and then the second thing is that
half the time i had no idea what we were
doing when it came to the
giant action set pieces it's like i put
all my faith in justin
and justin was like okay now reach out
for jacob and
and you guys are and like look left and
i was like god i really hope you make me
look cool justin because i have no idea
what we're doing right now
because oftentimes it just comes
together you know because of a mixture
of what the stunt team is doing
and and cgi and um they he made it look
awesome so i'm really glad i look like a
badass but half the time i was
totally faking it yeah i think a lot of
people don't realize that like
i think but maybe some people realize
but i think at this point some people
are like wait the actors aren't even
there it's
you know there's a lot of cgi magic
right there's a lot of magic and and
oftentimes the only one who really knows
what's happening is the mastermind
justin behind it all
right you know how much do you
obviously they're making another two
films after this how much are you
pulling justin aside and being like so
tell me what's going to be happening
when are we filming the next one
a lot i do it a lot i'm pretty shameless
i'm like every time like justin even
even yesterday i saw justin between
interviews and and i was like so what's
up justin like what timeline are you
thinking and uh where do you think we're
headed
and uh i've got a couple ideas for mia
um
so i i can't imagine how torture
torturous it must be for justin because
you know there's so many of us
i mean it's like and and we're all
trying to like put our two cents in
but justin's really really gracious but
but yeah i
i do that a lot i'm i'm texting him a
ton
he told me that he will not be filming
it this year he said the earliest is
next year has he told you that
yes he did he's such an honest dude
that's what i love about justin
is like he's so not hollywood and um
he's been that way from the very
beginning i shot annapolis with him
and then he he signed on for tokyo drift
while he was on the annapolis set which
was really cool because then tyreese and
i
were already a part of the universe then
he became a part of the universe
and um he has so much integrity i mean
there
there are characters that are in fast 9
or f9
that were also from annapolis which he's
constantly recycling actors it's really
cool
uh i know that you have two other
projects that you shot um
the integrity of joseph chambers and on
our way uh what can you tease about both
of those projects
i'm so so on our way was this was this
wonderful film i shot in new york during
the pandemic
and i'm really really excited to see it
and it's it's definitely a departure for
me and then the integrity of joseph
chambers i got to work with
robert machoian who is genius
and um and claine who i had worked with
on lethal weapon who
really really gets i mean if you've seen
the last film he did
um with robert i mean it's so brilliant
and they both get to showcase their
talent
and so i'm just so happy to be along for
the ride and hopefully i get to work
with them
a bit more but it definitely allowed me
to show a different
side um which i'm really excited about
and hopefully it goes the festival route
uh my last thing for you uh were you a
little disappointed that you didn't get
to be
in the outer space sequence the people
who were involved told me it was a lot
of it was a challenging
shoot no i'm super relieved one because
everyone initially was like
how are they gonna do that how are they
gonna pull that off so and and also i
think
tonally it was perfect for roman and tej
to do it because
they are the comic relief so i think it
was
perfect that they were the ones to do it
and
sort of make it a little bit
tongue-in-cheek because there had to be
humor within it too
to show like we're not taking ourselves
way too seriously and also i would not
want to wear all of that gear
like i think that's so uncomfortable i
i'm super claustrophobic so
so so please no talk of a fast and
furious in space i think it would be
miserable
um so so no i was really happy not to be
a part of that i
i like kicking ass in tokyo was for me
yeah natsugan's is great listen uh
congrats on everything
and i wish you nothing but the best and
i hope this is a huge hit because i want
to see the next one
totally thank you me too